nous allons reprendre le train parler du
train pendulaire le pendolino italien
qui fait ses premiers essais en ce
moment sur la ligne paris limoges
solution économique pour la sncf il
évite contrairement aux tgv de créer des
lignes nouvelles
dans ce plan d'eau lino présenté hier
vous allez voir que louis gallois le
patron la sncf s'est fait quelque peu
usé par les syndicalistes
l'ugb aziz un daniel et fille dans un
wagon du pando lino un train pendulaire
italien transformé en laboratoire de
mesure pour la sncf à bord
apparemment rien de bien différent et
pourtant un train pendulaire comme un
vélo ou une moto se penche pour aborder
un virage c'est le cas ici en simulation
regardez maintenant en situation
le tableau de bord s'incline par rapport
à la ligne d'horizon
tout cela pour quoi pour gagner en
moyenne 15% de vitesse supplémentaire
sur les bois non tgv déjà existantes
autre avantage la gêne évidente subie
par le passager dans un virage et qui
peut atteindre 20 % de son poids
disparaît pratiquement par l'inclinaison
artificielle du train
on envisage d'installer ce genre de
train pour deux raisons essentielles
plus de confort pour le voyageur il n'y
a plus cette accélération est plus vite
dans les courbes donc des gains de temps
pour les ja mais ce projet a une cause
principalement économique puisqu'il
permet d'accélérer la vitesse des trains
sans faire de frais pour la création de
lignes nouvelles
si vous voulez construire une voie
nouvelle sur paris limoges c'est plus de
10 milliards
l'adaptation de la voie aux pendulaires
c'est de l'ordre du milliard
c'est à dire que c'est dix fois moins
pour cette présentation du train
pendulaire à la presse dans chaque gare
certains cheminots attendait leur
président écoutez cette année cette
année on mute on augmente de 50% les
embauches
les embauches et oui on a fait 3100
embauches l'an dernier on en faire
quatre mille cinq cents cette année de
pause ça sera deux mille deux cents
cette année au lieu de 4500 ya qu'à
l'avenir de la sncf ne se dessine donc
pas uniquement sur les rails mais
également dans les rangs